let's get to our doctor david agus who
joins us from his home in los angeles dr
aegis good morning
we have not one but two bits of hopeful
news out of the world of medicine today
so let's start with that drug
rem deserver dr anthony fauci cautiously
optimistic about it it's an anti-viral
drug which means it blocks the virus
from replicating
what more can you tell us about it
you know in mid-january it was my first
meeting on covid19 and literally every
day since then we've dreamt of the
moment we could say
we have a drug that we know works and we
can say that
here a thousand patients decreasing
hospitalization by four days the death
rate is down about 30 percent although
it's not statistically significant
so very powerful these are treating
people who we call moderately to
severely ill
they're short of breath and they're very
symptomatic
classically with antivirals the earlier
you treat the more
outcome clinical outcome you get and the
better it is so seeing this at this
stage
is very encouraging we have something in
our arsenal
to treat the disease that is exciting
very very encouraging indeed are there
any caveats in your mind anything we
should be looking out for
no i mean this is you know the study has
not been peer reviewed and so that's
important
is that this is the nih study which the
initial data were released yesterday
now it's going to be reviewed and the
fda will assign it
hopefully approval so it can be used in
mass across the country and the company
is giving away the first million and a
half doses
of this for free to the country for
treatment of pavement patients with
covet 19.
yeah nih double blind known as a gold
standard study in the way it was
organized now let's go to oxford
university talk about a vaccine
scientists there think they may have a
vaccine ready by september
way earlier than otherwise scheduled how
promising is that
it's pretty wild i mean this is the
university that survived the plague in
the 1300s
but they had developed a vaccine for
mers a former virus
that did you know was tried in patients
did not uh
spread the virus so the vaccine was
shelved and they just switched out the
portion from mers
to covet 19 and put it into monkeys
and challenge monkeys with the virus
after 28 days
no signs or symptoms from the virus at
all so because it had already been in
patients a similar virus
they're starting out with 6 000 patients
over the next six weeks
so dramatically scaled and then if
that's positive they're going to go
forward with literally millions of doses
to try to get this very soon into people
across the globe
so big big step vaccine equals we will
be on top of this disease so
new drug vaccine certainly an amazing
day in the fight against covenant 19.
first positive one in a while
yeah that's right and dr agus we should
mention that you've also had
conversations with the white house
yourself personally about fast
tracking a vaccine what can you tell us
about that
it's called operation warp speed and the
key thing is is that there are
up to 70 companies now with vaccine
candidates and so what the government
and others are trying to do is say
i think these four or five are probably
the best let me start
making them and manufacturing in case
the trials work
so take the risk now don't wait to see
which works or which wins the bake off
start making the lead candidates now so
when the data are there
the next day we can roll it out across
the country it's key to think forward
all right dr david agus with that
insight into two bits of hopeful news
this morning thank you very much